hi there good evening everybody thank
you so much for being here tonight
grant grew up in a cooking family his
parents owned a restaurant he stood on
milk crate and cooked on the line with
them at that point I went to culinary
school at the Culinary Institute of
America in Hyde Park New York and then
worked in some of the best restaurants
in the country including two stretches
at the French Laundry with Thomas Keller
in French Laundry was a point in my
career where I realized that food could
be art and he really showed us an
expressive way to cook and it became
very apparent to me at that point that I
could continue that evolution take it
even further and when it came time to go
to trio and eventually Alinea it became
basically the most important aspect of
what we do and then opened Alinea in
Lincoln Park in 2005 the next year
ignore May called it the best restaurant
in America which is pretty good work if
you can get it and this summer he won
the James Beard Award as the outstanding
chef in the United States and if that
wasn't enough he was going through some
pretty intense personal stuff he was
diagnosed with lung cancer I learned
that I really love what I do because
despite what was going on I still wanted
to come to work every day you know I
could have easily like I had the best
excuse in the world like nobody was
gonna nobody was gonna call me out and
be like you know I can't believe the
chef's not here today like if I didn't
want to come to work I wouldn't nobody
would have thought otherwise you know
but I didn't I didn't want to come to
work and and you know it really were a
lot of people when they're facing the
life-threatening illness they asked
themselves like well what do I need to
accomplish in my life what do I need to
do what do I need to do different and
the answer for me was nothing I'm doing
I mean is it yeah all right now I feel
like a real TV chef
so we quarter the apples we quorum we're
gonna throw them in the pot with apple
cider while that's cooking I'm going to
take down this pheasant here so in this
preparation we're only going to use the
breast of the pheasant again employing
some technology we're gonna do what we
call cooking in sous-vide certainly
technology becomes a very powerful
creative tool for us it gives us more
options more ways to manipulate the food
and unexpected in new ways and it just
becomes a creative outlet for us now I
have some of the Apple chalet already
set this is where you would cut your
commercial on it
facial greatly
well that perfect eight out of the oven
and what's next for you I mean what do
you see sort of on the horizon well we
still have a lot to accomplish here at
the restaurant and you know that's
that's the beauty of it so it's a
constant evolution it never nothing he's
ever old you know it so there is no end
point there is no there is no finish
line it just continues you know that and
so I'm sure there'll be other projects
I'm sure we'll want to do another
cookbook at some point eventually
they'll probably be other restaurants
but right now we're just focused on
what was the goal in putting together
the ammonia well we wanted a book that
exemplified the restaurant captured the
energy the creativity the passion that's
involvement it every day unfortunately
once the book is printed it's done you
can't change it unless you add a web
component that continually grows with
content and material it's our way of
continually evolving or starting over
reinventing the cookbook what does the
money mean Alinea means the beginning of
a new train of thought which at the time
when we opened the restaurant three and
a half years ago it had a lot of
meetings it was obviously my first
restaurant so you certainly have to
shift your thinking when you open your
first restaurant your first business but
more importantly it was it was about the
food about about the experience that we
were trying to create it being new and
different and just kind of rethinking
fine dining in general all right so we
have our cooked pheasant breast square
it off and then you're gonna cut queues
I have here have another ingredient of a
fall which is like that roasted
vegetables like Carmelite the entire
staff we have 52 and we feed anywhere
from 70 to 90 people a night so it's a
tremendous amount of labor force to feed
that few of people and it breaks about
5050 so 25 in the kitchen cooks working
from 6:00 in the morning until 3:00 in
the morning we pass each other you know
when I'm leaving at 3 in the morning the
Baker's coming in to get going to start
a stay so if you know a tremendous
amount of work and resources go into
what we do on a nightly basis
what's your favorite part of the day
what you probably the very end you know
where I like it it's quiet
I'm alone I'll come out and sit in the
dining room with my notepad and do what
I love to do which is create start
coming up with new ideas new dishes so
we take our branches and like a bamboo
skewer you just skewer the three items
on the end here do the pheasant laughs
cause it's gonna hold everything on
these guys are giving you the smell of
autumn
what we're trying to tap into is the
mind and and try to evoke certain
memories and people for instance the
smell of a roasting apple pie you know
you might have fond memories of opening
that oven door or grandmother's house
and having that smell walked out and
you're transported back to when you were
8 years old and we try to harness those
things and bring them forward to the
guest so that it goes beyond eating it
goes beyond dinner it becomes something
much more people would actually smell
that and start to cry you know we really
want to make make the experience beyond
just putting food in your in your
stomach you know it really is about
evoking these emotions and making it the
aftrica land entertaining and having you
laugh and perhaps having you cry and in
the best possible way that's really what
Alenia is all about